in this video I want to talk about
beta-oxidation which is essentially the
process by which we break down fatty
acids specifically for energy or for
what will become energy where does this
process occur it occurs in the
mitochondrial matrix and we'll see why
that makes sense in just a moment so I
just said that we're breaking down a
fatty acid that's not entirely true
we're instead breaking down an activated
fatty acid which is an acyl koay okay so
notice what I've drawn here is this a so
go away here with these first two
carbons next to the carbonyl being shown
the reason why I did that is because
what do we call the carbon that's right
next to the carbonyl carbon which is
this carbon here we call it the Alpha
carbon the one right next to it would be
considered the beta carbon right so if
this is beta oxidation we would expect
to see that this beta carbon is oxidized
and that's actually what happened or
what happens excuse me
so this process beta oxidation is only
four steps the first one being an
oxidation step and this is actually the
first oxidation step as there is more
than just one so now in this first
oxidation step we're taking an acyl Co a
and returning it what are we doing from
here from this ASIC away we're turning
it into a transient oil co a so why is
this called transient oil co a well we
made it this double bond here between
the alpha and beta carbon so we lost two
of those hydrogen's losing hydrogen's is
oxidation so this a soakaway was
oxidized this trans Ino Elco a why is
it's called trans e no alcohol a I'm not
really sure what this oil means what
this mean the in portion of the in oil
comes from this alkene here this double
bond and what it is called trans because
this are this long our chain is trans to
this the part with the substituent with
the co a on it okay
but in any case it's a SoCo a is
oxidized a transient co a so something
else must have been reduced in fact
we're taking an F ad and turning it into
an fadh2 so we've reduced F ad to fadh2
which can yield us energy
once we have this trends in Ocoee
there's this hydration step what do you
imagine a hydration step to do if you
want to hydrate yourself you drink some
water
right so it's exactly what this step
here is involved in so in the hydration
step we're going to add water across
this double bond double bond and
actually I forgot to put the enzyme name
up here before I continue on with
hydration step this a SoCo a was
converted to this transgenic away by a
SoCo a dehydrogenase we lost those
hydrogen's so dehydrogenase it's a redox
addition reduction reaction anyway sorry
about that so here at this second step
hydration step we're adding water across
this double bond so the O H is going to
go onto the beta carbon and the other
the H will go onto the Alpha carbon so
what we get is this L beta hydroxy a
soak away well does this name make sense
well we have a hydroxy acyl specifically
it's a beta hydroxy ASO
so this is an acyl co way but with a
hydroxyl group on the beta carbon so oh
s group on the beta carbon beta hydroxy
a soak away why is L well this beta
carbon now is chiral it has one two
three four different substituents so in
this case it actually is l co
stereochemistry I didn't draw it that
way
didn't need to get too complicated just
want you to see what's going on here so
this is the hydration step this step is
catalyzed by an oil co a hydratase which
makes sense it's it's hydrating you know
l co a so so we get this L beta hydroxy
a soak away once we have this L beta
hydroxy a soak away we have our third
step which is actually our second
oxidation step so in our second
oxidation step we're taking L beta
hydroxy a soak away and turning into
beta keto a soak away so what's going on
here what have we done well it's an
oxidation stew
we're oxidizing this beta carbon we're
turning it from an OHA
write to a carbonyl so it's more bonds
to oxygen which which is an oxidation
step in addition we lost these
hydrogen's so you can think about it as
the loss of the hydrogen's or you can
think about it as more bonds to oxygen
so in this case this L beta hydroxy a so
Co a is oxidized so something else is
reduced and in this case we're taking an
nad plus and reducing it to an NADH
this step is catalyzed by beta hydroxy
acyl Co a dehydrogenase so now we have
this beta key to a Sol Co a excuse me so
why does this name make sense
well beta ketone right this carbon has a
carbon on either side of it so it's a
beta ketone and it's an a so co a so now
what we're going to do with this step is
fourth step and last step of beta
oxidation is the cleavage step and in
this step if you were actually going to
cut this beta keto isoko a right here
notice that if you look on the right
side of that dotted purple line we
essentially have an acetyl co a over
here we just have an acyl group on this
left side so what we're going to do is
we're going to add a coenzyme a right
via the enzyme called file ace thiolase
so we're going to make a bond to this
this sulfur group hence the thiolase
portion there to it we're going to add
it here to make to make this acetyl co a
cop hop off which is what we have here
so we have we've free up an acetyl co a
and actually write that in a different
color we free up in a CTO Co a right
here which is a two carbon molecule so
we knock we cut off two carbons and then
we're left with this acyl group that we
attach a co a to so we'll end up with
this a soakaway which is what we started
with right we started with an acyl co a
how is this one different well this one
is now two carbons shorter
this one that we started with was right
because this a acetyl co a which is two
carbons long was cut off the original
thing so now that we have this a so Co a
that is now two carbons shorter then
what we started with that's really
terrible writing I really apologize but
in any case what's important is that now
we have this a SoCo a that's two carbons
shorter it's essentially it can start
off the process again it's ready for
another round of beta-oxidation so this
thing can go through all four of these
steps all over again okay so now what's
important to keep in mind about
beta-oxidation well what happens in each
round each round of beta-oxidation
results in one fadh2 one NADH and one to
see Tokyo a the first oxidation step
yielded an fadh2 the second one you live
in ADH and both of those things will go
to the electron transport chain to be
reoxidized for energy what about this
acetyl co way though where have we seen
acetyl co way before we saw it in the
TCA cycle the Krebs cycle so it'll go to
the Krebs cycle and when they when one
acetyl co a goes through the Krebs cycle
we get three nadh --is we get one fadh2
and we get one GTP this idea here is
very very important to keep in mind when
we think about how to calculate the
energy that we get from a particular
length of a fatty acid okay and we'll
get to this in it and then in the future
videos thank you for watching I hope
that was helpful